[Music]
the show for 40 years that's it that's
what I tell myself I early I from now
she wears the dress every day I would do
Costanza with the Yankees that was a
little bit there you go a bit before I
love it cuz I feel like for you I felt
like when I was doing a talk show I was
doing as I was doing all the stuff and
everyone was telling me to be myself and
I was like okay I feel like I can take
that note but then I quickly learned
that like myself is not super adorable
or even but like you know America they
didn't want you know I realize like
mirror America wants like a like cleaner
less angry less nasal version of myself
but for you I feel like that advice
actually applies like be yourself well
do I have to change myself a lot to work
on these camera is it is it a lady fella
thing do you think do you think America
is more accepting of a friendly looking
guy that's like but if you if you do it
looking all gorgeous keep it sexy I got
to look dainty I have to be to get I got
stickers I have stickers on my boobs
I mean literal scratches I mean I've
been getting ready since noon I'm still
thinking about your panties
there is nothing I could do yeah that
would be as distracting as what you just
did if you pulled out your nuts it'd be
pretty the way you present yourself I
feel like they're not in great shape
I feel like they're pretty pretty
loosey-goosey down there but that's
warming about you the idea that my nuts
are loosey-goosey Conan gave me their
show cuz he's like this fellas got a
swinging ball so I just you're so like
authentic you're not like most la guys
who like well are trying to be someone
they're not do you feel like an LA
person
I don't know I know Sally I don't I'm
not really a Hollywood person yeah I
don't think you are yeah that's not my
thing
I feel like comedians are a little bit
exempt from that when people say when I
tell people I like LA people are
surprised but I think it's because I
only hang out with comedian because no
one else want to hang out with us
[Music]